good morning everybody good morning to
those
watching live on youtube we're now
meeting face-to-face for the first time
for can't think how many months
certainly since beginning of last year
cannot hear margaret
not very well i'll shout
um so welcome to everybody this morning
the plans give me the meeting
um i'll ask the committee
and officers to introduce themselves so
we'll start at that end with councillor
if you'd like to introduce yourself can
you richard bowden i represent our heart
award
margaret brown i represent great
character brothers
and i represent two rivers and three
wars
philip pennington monkey and putford
good morning my name is peter christie i
was in biddeford north
hi i'm ruth craigie i represented the
east
hello richard wiseman i represent the
chevy and landry
good morning everybody chris leather and
i represent northern
so if the officers would like to
introduce themselves starting
on my right please uh sean harrington
playing manager of toronto
good morning james jackson development
management and team leader
district council good morning stacy dory
head of natural governance district
council
and we've got sandra our clark and tom
are technical whiz kid
who keep everything running this morning
right item one on the agenda
is apologist for absence we've got a
full house
chair apology from councillor watson
councillor pennington substituting thank
you sandra thanks for that
item two on the agenda is the minutes of
our last meeting
on pages five to twenty three
and this is the meeting of the thirtieth
of march
[Music]
please raise your hand i think it's
recording
[Music]
okay
chancellor brown or chancellor christie
or
chancellor craigie or dancer leather or
chancellor locke or pencil mcgrath
chancellor wiseman or chancellor
pennington
not on the committee but president of
the meeting and four for the minutes to
be a correct
record thank you that you know mr
item three on the agenda is declarations
of interest
members with interest to declare should
refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interest when the action is being
considered
elected members of devon county council
and town
and parish councils who've considered a
planning application by virtue of their
membership
of that council all the personal
interests
and are deemed to have considered the
application separately
and the express views of that council do
not bind the members concern
who consider the application of fresh
item 4 on the agenda is
uh agreements between parts one and two
there is no part two
in general i can find on the agenda
is urgent practice i've been working
the planning manager thank you
item six is of public participation
it is expected that
all who attend the plans committee then
they will give a fair
and uninterrupted year into the planning
officer giving their
report and to all those listed to speak
and to their planning committee business
when they begin their consideration
after all it is only common courtesy
that we're giving each other a fair
hearing
and we've got today we've got two
speakers
the ritual application four speakers
for the hybrid redstone hybrid hill one
four speakers after lunch for the east
pocket one
one speaker for the uh
slate cottage at children application
two speakers for the buck garden street
application
and one the torridge torres road one now
right item seven on the agenda is
planning application
can i declare interest
i live in a west west country property
planning applications and the
information and recommendations
and the advice contained in the reports
are correct
at the date of preparation which is more
than 10 days in advance of the committee
meeting due to these time constraints
any changes or necessary updates to the
reports
will be provided in writing or orally
at the committee meeting so we move on
into 7a which is our first application
which is on pages 24 to 48
and this is the
i'll get to that and this is the
application
and james jackson planning baptism
thanks james thank you chair uh good
morning and good morning members good
morning members of the public watching
on
youtube um obviously i'm trying to speak
quite clearly and loudly given
circumstances but if you can't hear me
then please um
uh so this is like seven eight that's
the chair said this is application one
slash one double 008
2020 fql uh full application seeking
planning commission for the erection of
night of
the valiance access and associated
workers planning during
our rise in bridge rule um just a quick
verbal update
uh prior since the publication of the
agenda we have received
one
immediately to the west of the site
the issues that have been raised are
that
the proposal would result in light
intrusion cars
accessing plots eight and nine uh
concerns regarding the culvert
and watercourse along the shared
boundary
concerns regarding flooding and the data
set that has been used
in terms of the flood risk assessment
and
also concern raised that land drainage
consent
is required for devon county council and
also concern raised about maintenance
of the proposed attenuation pond and
also
about parking bays that are proposed
along the road
so the these issues have been considered
in full
in your officer's report the objective
had made
a previous objection which raised the
same issues um
so from your officer's perspective these
issues have been covered and don't
affect recommendations
next slide please
okay so on the left here we have a site
location plan which is edged
in red uh this shows um the
the regular shape site it's a parcel of
agricultural land
we can see on the eastern western and
southern sides
existing residential development there
the site slopes up from its southern
boundary towards the north all leveling
off
the location of the former canal and
levels off
towards the north on
the right hand side put a slide there
this is the site location plan
relating to a planning commission that's
previously been granted on this site
the nine open market plannings
that remains an f-stop permission is a
material consideration
in the consideration of the current
proposal you can see
the uh the site uh extents are different
um but obviously the point being is that
the
the
location plan on the right establishes
the principle of residential development
of
the majority of the site that you are
considering today uh the exception to
that is obviously a partner part of the
site which is like in the northwestern
corner which is
is effectively a new part of the site
that hasn't been previously found
next slide there's just a couple of
aerial images of the site on the left we
have a close-up
uh the blue dot marks the site so there
you can see
the open agricultural nature of that
site
and the existing residential development
on the eastern
southern and western sides we also have
the public highway running along the
southern boundary
um and sort of mature hedgerows around
the southern east and western boundaries
and also standard mature trees up along
forming the northern boundary the right
hand side
every image just shows a zoomed out
aerial image which just shows the
context of the site
bridge rule you can see here that it's
on located on the western edge of the
village
our next slide is
this is the proposed site plan we can
see the access
to be created through the southern
boundary of the site and then a single
spine road
going up into the site and the nine
proposed dwellings
arranged around that spine road uh the
first
three plots fronting onto the public
highway
with the remainder of the fox sort of
carrying on up into the site
each of the box has a dedicated private
community space
as well as two dedicated car parking
spaces
in terms of pops one and two these have
been provided along
uh the edge of the public highway
with the parking for blocks
three to nine um located outside the
valley
with the site down in the southwestern
corner of the site we can see
a hose attenuation pod there which is
proposed to deal with
surface water and wood
drain discharge to the existing water
force which runs down the western
boundary of the site that then goes
under the public highway via a culvert
goes around the existing cycle
development to the south before
ultimately discharging to the to the
river taylor
other points to note in terms of the
northern boundary
uh on the cyclone there that's born from
a
hedge fund we also have two
areas which aren't particularly clear on
this on this drawing but up in
on the western and eastern boundaries
there's space there
left for an ecological buffer which
would effectively be an undeveloped
um space which would be between the
existing hedgerows
and the rio gardens box one and fox 9.
all of the existing trees and hedgerows
are
to be retained on the northern
eastern and western boundaries the um
boundary to the southern uh binary the
existing hedgerow there would be removed
which would be replaced with exist with
debit hedge banks that obviously the
point at which
the access comes in
next slide please
so this slide shows the proposed access
here this is the specification for that
showing that visibility can be achieved
in both directions
of 43 meters which is what is required
by
the local highways authority for this
location
uh we can see the width of the
carriageway there
is increased and we can see obviously
the relationship of that existing access
um on the servers the size of the side
of the hills development over in the
south
east corner um just that relationship
between that
access and the access
next slide please
this is just the detailed designs of the
various dwellings this is box one and
two
we can see here traditional traditional
design really
we've got wide-rendered walls external
walls
great concrete tile roofs
individual torches and also there's so
many device individuality
provided by different kind of doors
across the development
also got some variation in roof lights
as well just like some
interest there next slide please
this is plot three moving uh along the
site from
uh east to west this is still fronting
onto the highway
and some variation in the design here
again at first floor level you can see
uh hanging tile introduced the ground
floor is still
rendered next slide please
support four and five again rendered
properties with great
guitar roots next slide please
six and seven uh again we have rendered
to the ground floor with hanging tile to
the
first floor and also uh hanging tile to
the gamer length
next slide please
finally plots eight and nine um
following the
same um design style again with some
variation in the
roof height uh and again quite friendly
and properties there next slide please
so just take you through some
photographs here these two have stood
within the site the first one on the
left is looking
um from pretty much within the center of
the site looking east that's over
towards the
canal rise development back in towards
fridge
on the right hand side is looking sort
of
southeast that's over the existing side
fields development which is
predominantly
existing bungalows next slide please
on the left here this is looking back
across the site to the western boundary
uh you can't see obviously on this photo
but that's where the watercourse
is rooted down along through that
boundary before conflicting underground
and on the right hand side this is
looking uh
from the top of the site back across
northeast where the site levels out at
the top
um along the alignment of the forward
canal that's back up to existing
residential development and another
public highway which is
beyond the site to the north next slide
please
this photograph on the left hand side is
from the public highway but up at the
northern
extent of the site looking back towards
the site those trees that you can see on
the right hand side
call the parts of the northern reach of
the site
on the right hand side i'm stood there
in the
public highway to the southeast of the
side of the southwestern corner
that's looking back across the site and
in the background there you can see it
can now rise above the back
next slide please
left hand picture is the existing
watercourse that flows down
between the site and the western
boundary this is proposed
um where the attenuation pond would
discharge to
or ultimately going down to the river
and on the right hand side this is taken
from the public highway
site this is the access into the uh
existing
south hills department next slide please
this is a public highway looking from
the south eastern corner of the site
looking back
across the west on the right hand side
there we just have the
telephone exchange which is just beyond
the site's eastern bank
next slide please
photograph on the left is just to show
the existing
um varied character within the street
scene on the approach to the cyclist is
just over to the east
and on the western side of the right
hand
photograph shows the access of the
existing property immediately west of
the site
next slide please
so material considerations in this case
are
the principle of development character
appearance presidential immunity
biodiversity highways flood risk and
surface water drainage and
infrastructure
in terms of the principle it is a
countryside location and therefore
sto 7 applies we the
proposal does also satisfy the exception
policy within the local plan st 19
which supports the exceptional release
of land where
there is a demonstrable lead for
affordable housing which we have in this
case
um we also as as committee will be aware
and currently the cannot demonstrate
five years
by housing land and therefore in
accordance with the npdpf we do have to
undertake a tilted balance which
effectively
uh involves weighing up the matters that
weigh a favor and proposal of those
adverse impacts coming to a conclusion
as to whether those adverse impacts
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits
in terms of the character appearance um
see the site is
located with existing residential
development audits east and western and
southern side
in that context in your office's view
the proposal is well designed with
traditional
materials and traditional form and there
are no public rights way within close
proximity to
in terms of residential amenity we have
had obviously some objections as
highlighted
uh from in terms of the uh objection
from the occupier to the west of the
site
there is the concern about cars
entering the site from blockchain
tonight and those car lights shine
through there
shining through their bedroom windows we
have revised the scheme so that there is
a closer board event
behind those parking bays which in your
office view will mitigate that issue
um the the occupier of the adjacent
dwelling is also
projected on the basis of flooding
and it's your officer's view for the
music setup
in terms of biodiversity a number of
recommendations
from the survey of the site which are
conditioned in your office's report
and also enhancements in terms of the
proposed
uh buffer areas we've also got the
northern boundary and devon hedge bank
and um also birder back boxes are also
paged on the site in terms of highways
the local uh highways
authorities confirm that they have no
objections proposals subject to a number
of conditions which are set out in your
report
and um the visibility which is required
to be achieved as shown on the
those plans then in terms of flood risk
of surface water drainage
we have had a number of revisions that
have taken to
the scheme to ensure that we get to a
point where
the uh drainage engineers are happy with
the scheme
they've now confirmed that the
projection will be in fact there will be
a betterment
to the surface water drainage within the
area
the condition that's recommended also
includes
a requirement for the applicant to
undertake a survey of the existing
culvert and make good
any repairs that are necessary in terms
of its capacity to deal with
um any of the surface water
but in effect the surface water scheme
mimics
greenfield performance with allowance
for climate change
as well in terms of infrastructure
we do have obviously the affordable
dwellings that
pose in an area where there is a need
in terms of green space unfortunately we
do have regard to the exam commission
and that extent commission basically
spills a 106
or muted sum for 30 percent of
affordable that's all which would equate
to 2.7 dwellings
which that would need to be finally
cited for
that money to be spent on commuted sun
and that was
so i do have to have regards to that in
terms of how much we can negotiate for
this
um proposal in your office's view this
proposal is obviously a betterment to
that um which uh the extant mission
by virtue of 100 affordable schemes
being provided
on the site um there is a question
obviously about whether this is a
balanced scheme in terms of its
uh tenure of housing because it's 100
affordable there's no open market on
this scheme
i do think we need your in your office's
view we do need to have
uh an approach where we look at that in
the round and in terms of the
overall um village of bridge rule and
in that case your officers are satisfied
that it would not
unacceptably sort of tip the balance in
terms of the overall
exposing within um the settlement
it's also worth noting as well that the
policy st-17
the supporting tax of that policy makes
clear that the
policy only applies to major development
as well in terms of
trying to achieve a balanced housing mix
and this this proposal does not fall
into that major classroom
and so in conclusion taking all those
matters into account
is your opposite view that the adverse
impacts would not
um outweigh significantly into
monsoonally the
benefits to the scheme and it's
therefore recommended that uh
thank you james thank you for that
presentation
we've got two speakers for this
application
speaking first in support is samantha
nolback
in support of the proposed development
we've got up here
sorry we can't hear a word okay i'll
speak up sorry
today i am speaking in support of the
preparedness development
on behalf of westwood housing group
social housing
can we foreign the windows behind us
there's a digger working in the
background bringing your drone into the
windows here
is that convenient or not allowed to do
so
i'm sorry i'll try here
okay so today i am speaking in support
of the proposed development
on behalf westwood housing group a
social housing provider
formerly known as tarka housing and as
the co-chair of devon rural housing
partnership who specialise in
communities
and delivering housing in rural areas
such as bridgeworld
both organizations are in support of the
proposed
100 affordable housing scheme actually
arise in bridgeworld
the site has in part the benefit of
outline planning consent
and so the principle of development has
been agreed
through the planning process the design
team have addressed all concerns
raised by consultees and by the local
residents to arrive at a detailed scheme
prevented here today
the outcome of this application was due
in december
2020 and as a charity these delays have
impacted us significantly in terms of
delivery and grant funding
these nine much-needed affordable homes
in this rural location
are on a site which already has outlined
client consent for nine houses
and will be for a mix of rented and
shared ownership
would have already had several inquiries
from local residents who may be eligible
for these properties once built
they have been advised to register with
the relevant platforms depending on the
suitable tenure for their circumstances
which is seven home choice for a rental
property and help to buy sell for a
shared ownership property
this information has also been provided
through the parish council
throughout our engagement with them we
look forward to a positive outcome from
today's committee meeting
and delivering these much needed homes
the residents of torridge
thank you thank you for that
my next speaker our next speaker for
this
application is board member councillor
james
everybody um you may think it's a bit
strange for somebody who's campaigned
for
affordable housing in norway areas for
30 to 40 years
i find myself in this photo it could be
a position where i'm not so much against
the development
is there's issues with it and individual
when you read the reports it talks about
that we've done
no affordable housing for several years
we've done three schemes
which was the bungalow one um
and the thing that we've done as a
publisher and i'm speaking mostly as a
parish councillor
as well as the world member the schemes
that we've done
one undermining theme and that is the
cooperation between the planning
department
the developer and the community on this
one
we haven't either get a local level so
i realize we're in covert and i'm not
into the conspiracy theory that well two
people have got
that things are popping up during kobe
because it's going to be more convenient
so i dismiss that straight away
but the thing about it is that we've
been as a parish
we've set a trend um with the
one you saw which is it says it's mainly
gone ghost but it's some bungalows
and some up down so don't hoses because
thing was bridging
it's very up and down hill yeah we're in
the bottom of the basin we've got the
river table
and we've got a lot of flooding you know
um a large part of my cloud floods
most of the winter and we're having a
lot of trouble with water that road
that you showed where this has joined in
does flow
quite regularly during the winter and
there's not so much
uh the water coming off the sides you've
got an awful lot of water coming down
the road
and the stream it's going into you've
heard uh officers say that the
um the colder needs to be investigated
and we get a lot of trouble with that
because obviously rubbish washes into
hold us
but also the stream that takes it when
the back of um
what is the sunny bank development where
the bunk roads are upside down actually
because the amount of rain is struck
since well august september time
the banks are collapsing and that stream
is actually blocking
so i know the landowner who's my
next-door neighbor
is thinking he's gonna
because when it gets right down the end
before it gets to
tamar turned under another culvert that
then blocks and floods the rest of the
village
so we have got issues you know and what
the village wanted
was some discussion about this
development
about where we were going with it so in
terms of what we've done
on that development we acquired the
playing field
you know we worked with the developer
what could go into the community
and we had a football team with no pitch
we had a farmer's field
so we got that we also got some play
equipment
on the little bridge development which
was the first
development in torridge which was across
across subsidised affordable housing we
built about
20 houses 26 houses that happened
five were self-built sites uh five were
affordable so that fitted with uh
s217 is being dismissed a little bit
because it's a small development
but the whole principle has been that
we've worked together
and uh we've developed stuff now the
problem with this side is
i don't think you realize just how steep
it is
if you look at the one photograph that
looked at
the telephone exchange which is one of
the main exchanges
that hold the north pole now often gps
are so reachable it's often open reach
facts there
which will cause an obstruction and the
argument put to me that we should have
to bring the police and down the boat
i can assure you that my wife goes down
i will not be winning the police against
the open reach valve
so there are a lot of issues where
they're not being addressed there is no
green area there's no player
no contribution to the community
the school is actually full i spoke to
the head teacher and they're very
writers are all
nine affordable values and if you read
the report it talks about
just over two primary school children
who talks about just over one
secondary school
and there are four and we've got i'm not
sure it's six or seven young children
so this is mine our school can only take
the number of children that lead at the
moment every year we cannot take more
because of other closures and is
school and in 2019 during the summer
holidays they built a measuring
classroom in the top
talking to
[Laughter]
right so the problem there is is purely
there's been no communication i won't go
down all that
there's been nothing parish council's
when you come to the site itself and it
seems to be forever moving work
and it has been slightly difficult um
because the
uh james not being that once much
but the drainage scheme has changed
three times
right and then i'm not gonna get system
work and you've got this large
attenuation pod
built into the hill on the side of a
affordable housing scheme that
presumably will have a lot of children
the footpath originally i've just been
told and then adjusting tool that's not
going to be changed
used to come down where those cars are
then you'd be stepping off the footpath
behind the gpo
place so you would have no visibility so
yeah it wouldn't be advisable to push it
but i'm not told that's gonna change and
this is a little bit of the issue here
is that what is the plan gonna look like
when it's finished
um it's very steep and if you look at
the cross section of the hoses
you will notice the ground level is
always i'm sorry you're doing that
right you always see kids in changing
room levels
and there's steps and if you went
through the back of the phone
right um if you notice here right
that is i think that's the gpo place
that's a house that's in the bottom of
the canal rise
and if you go back here they're all up
above roof level and i actually went to
that one the other day
and there are three steps that lead from
sort of this floor level down to the
below floor level
there is quite a height difference on
that side
and it's going to be for young children
now i'm not against having a vulnerable
host in the village
i just think there should be more
consultation um
this here is from the road level
is
is either this or we don't actually
accept one
point which is no better so i'll leave
it at that
thank you folks
that's the end of the country this
this application was um one of our
virtual site visits that we had
yesterday so
all the committee has seen the site in
detail
we'd like to start the discussion
councilor brown
thank you chairman i'd just like to
answer and comment
on what the last speaker said about
there being no communication
can can you give us an answer to that
please
send a chat um so this obviously as
us um councillor james says that is
slightly difficult during
um coping time i think there's a couple
of points
the the applicant has provided um some
emails that have been sent
to uh the parish council which indicate
that
the consultation was taken out
undertaken by by phone
because obviously things couldn't be
done in person um and i understand
so that's one point really i do
understand that that it would have been
preferable for some consultations to be
able to take it but
in in planitive there's not an actual
statutory requirement
for that to take place um so obviously
as with any development an african
can submit an application to the local
planning authority and they have to deal
with that and it's hilarious as we've
done
so um so really i fully agree it would
be much better for
african local parish community the
flag authority to sort of work with us
together but as i said
there's no statutory requirement to do
so and obviously has
changed the way that that's really
happened
counseling yeah i mean how many times
we sat at the plans committee and looked
at applications
and below the fact that they're only
offering 30
before and then they um submit a
viability appraisal which
is upheld by the district ban on that
one and that percentage gets knocked
down from 30
and sometimes it gets down to the poor
and yet here we are with
nine open market houses and there's
still some objections i take on
especially with regard to the flood
risks because i know from the report
that then county flood risk team
had withdrawn their objections after a
third response so they have obviously
worked hard on that
um and the environmental protection
officer is confident the traffic
movement plan the police have no
objections south west wall to have no
objections
and the educational authority has said
that there are
there's both spaces in the local primary
school and secondary schools which is
completely opposite
which council james has just told us
um a lot of the objections
were material planning objections um
but um they overcome the one objection
about the headlight shining in the
windows and they're going to put up a
fence
and i'm you know as long as there's a
strong
section 106 agreement for
the affordable houses whichever whether
it's um
affordable rent or shared ownership as
long as that's a strict
106 agreement that he started within the
from the prisoners of
british rule i would recommend that this
application is approved but i'll wait
for further comments
thank you thank you councilman one i'll
have a second action
of housing in british rule already
apparently there has been
three schemes as uh council james said
but that was more than 10 years ago so
if that's true is that true in the
report that those that provision was
more than 10 years ago we
won't get into it okay but that being
besides the point
um the the principal development is
already proven on most of the sites
because there's except extended planning
this seems to be an improvement for
locals local local
community so i'm happy with it thank you
councilman
thank you very much michelle i'm
slightly good at page 37
a section 106 agreement would be would
restrict the occupation of the homes
for those in need of affordable housing
and without connection
criterion can somebody just explain that
how can one of six restrict the
occupation
please sorry could you repeat that again
have you got page 37
in your agenda yeah yeah look at the top
section i think it's two footer points
down
a section 106 agreement will restrict
the occupation of the homes
to those in need of affordable housing
with a local connection
criterion age some clarity happens but
what does that actually mean yeah that's
yours
so so what that means is if this relates
really
really what we will have is a section
106 that restricts the properties to
being affordable i
can't be sold on the open market or
rented out open market properties
we'll also have a clause within there
that the first option will be a local
tie
to those within the parish of ritual and
it's only that if that clause can't be
satisfied that we've got to cascade it
outside
to the neighboring parishes and then go
from there really so the first point
will always be
the parish original to meet that local
need and also obviously the time will be
that they are affordable properties in
perpetuity i.e
thank you much for that that's that's
the main corruption really what i'm
trying to get is obviously
the bridge rule residence there
obviously the first choice
of these affordable dwellings and you
know not rare and anybody ever seen from
the village going in there but nothing
against that but foreign
thank you chair um i think you've
answered my questions i was going to ask
about the
flood risk um there is a betterment i
think it was stated in the reports
so um i am concerned there was three
rules of the situation and it said very
early on
that there was a low discharge
pronunciation from the developer but
that was concerned about the time you
get to the end of page 27
my question also relates that i note
from the enabling officer
that there was a need for 5 affordable
housing on page 31
third paragraph from the bottom and yet
it's nine units
now that's proposing have i got that
correct um
and what happens if we can't find
additional four loop
needs in the mean time to the housing
what happens then in that situation
okay thank you yeah so as clarified with
the strategic canadian officer the
current need is fine
she does indicate as well that obviously
year on year that's increased it
return from the applicant as well and
she's had a number of inquiries as well
this relates back to 106 really so the
106 will tie them as important
properties
and first of all within the parish
originals make sure if we beat that
openly
first then there will be the ability for
that to be cascaded to neighboring
parishes so
so that we could also like look at that
in terms of that need as well so
it's it's obviously the five at the
moment for that
when i ask are you convinced
that there will be no houses left empty
because they cannot beat that the only
provider should
the the nine be provided in this
application yes absolutely because
we've what we've seen from the strategic
enablers uh in nba offices
consultation responses that the need
across the district is obviously
pretty wide it's increased and it's
going to increase up to
2035 as well and i think this this
application
because it's driven by an affordable
housing provider
and that situation is slightly different
to a speculative development coming
across
from a developer or something and
obviously western housing are an
affordable housing provider so
it's it's slightly different obviously
their their um
position and their their reason for
being is to meet affordable needs so it
just like came spokes like a chair thank
you
thanks for craiging thank you i've got a
couple of concerns and
i'm concerned that um from what
councilor james said about the school
differing from what the county council
has said
and also about the flooding that there's
more flooding there
and the council is that section
that there isn't a flooding problem and
that's that's my main main concern my my
third concern is
what my all i always have for every
penny application
the car parking spaces are separate from
the houses
how are there going to be charging
points put
in before when they build
the parking spaces because it's always
so much more difficult to put in the
charging points after they've been built
okay thank you guys so on three points
there the first point in terms of the
school capacity
obviously as you've seen from your
office's report the
local education authority has confirmed
that there's
i understand from councillor james's
college that that's not the case so
we have gone back and checked that with
the local education authority
from their perspective there is capacity
within the school and
that's the first point on the flooding
point
as you've seen we did go through a
number of revisions but i think the
first point to know is that
this this development is only
responsible to mitigate its own impact
and not
not um solve existing issues that aren't
related to that development
so obviously but these kind of issues
cross over a bit because when i was on
site i didn't notice there was some
standing water
at one of my site visits in terms of in
the highway
and because of that obviously the
condition that's required in the
application
to undertake um an assessment of that
culvert
then that will i think improve that
existing positioning
and that is what the denver county
council drainage engineers
confirmed as well i think we also need
to consider again the exam permission
really
the exam commission obviously accepts
the principle of nine
dwellings and and the associated surface
water drainage with that
we look at the conditions that are on
that exam commission they require a
detailed
service water drainage to come forward
the
the information that was submitted with
that application from the applicant says
that they will first
look at infiltration as a potential we
know from this application that's not
possible because they're going to take
choke away testing and then in terms of
drainage hierarchy they'll move to an
attenuation system and discharge into
waterfalls
so what will actually happen if they
bring forward that
first the extant permission is that what
we will end up with
is is effectively a discharge into that
waterfalls anyway really
so now in terms of what we've got on
this current application
the condition is far more robust because
it actually requires them to undertake
the survey and the repairs that hold it
as well
um third point just on the parking um
i don't think there are any uh proposals
to install
electric charging points i do understand
that in
sort of going forward that is going to
be the way things move
but in terms of policy that's not
something we can require at this stage
in terms of
that and in terms of how they do related
plans i think personally
they do relate quite well to the
developments occasionally and
you've got the days for plots one and
two which are directly outside
properties
and then the base for each of the other
runnings which are in close proximity as
well
as well so it's not a situation where
you're gonna have a central car parking
board or anything like that they are
dedicated to it thank you
thank you james nobody else wants to
contribute
i want my say then well i'm not
agree with council a lot i was amazed to
see that there was
likely to be objections to nine
affordable houses being provided in
ritual
and when you read through the report on
and
we just discussed flooding
as it is now whatever runs off that site
plunges into the road
floods wherever there is a better i
accept whereas investment
councillor james mentioned about when it
crosses
adds to a stream further down through a
farmer's field etc
you can't be responsible for what
happens that far away from the state
in my view and i i do
i did look at the drainage issue
yesterday and
12 at sea definitely talks about
assessment and condition and capacity of
the culvert i don't think you can ask
any more than that you can't extrapolate
further and further and feel
what might happen off of ireland iowa
so i'm happy that they've addressed this
living the steepness of this study
is what it is now members may remember
the apple door application
so that the apple door community trust
wanted
i think put six the terrace of six hours
at a very very steep site
the rear gardens dropped down that is a
happening very steep
so the issue that the gardens aren't
going to be street
children will play them in any event
children will play the humans the
advantage
um
we've got to look at the again because
this is outside the development the
tilted balance
and in respect to the matter that just
say on page 43
the way in favor of the proposal that
proposed dine dwellings
would make a valuable contribution to
the housing stock within britain
at a time when the local planning
authority cannot demonstrate
the five-year-old land supply
significant weight
must be given to this issue it's also
noted that all nine dwellings
are will be affordable loans that would
meet the social needs of local persons
who are aiming to access properties
available on the open market
this factor adds further significance to
the weight in favor of the propulsion
to me it's and i hate this phrase no
brain
that's exactly what it is i it's got
[Music]
an except i really can't see why
bridal should be jumping up and down
when they talk about not being consulted
or not enough
discussion about it it's been known
about by the local councillors
and the parish clubs have known all
about this for months that it was coming
along
since their outline applications have
been so to say they didn't know anything
about it and that they weren't
informed i don't know what they wanted
they're
tourists to do exactly i'm
so if nobody else wants to speak
it
[Music]
or cancer craigie or
cancer leader or counselor
for counselor mcgrath or
chancellor wiseman or chancellor
pennington
that's unanimous chair thank you so much
right we move on to application
7b on page
we'll start on the next application
which is
[Music]
um
is
we just got air at all
looks like all right
[Music]
my name is peter stack i'm a graduate
planning officer at tourist
international council
i'm here to talk about the application
of redstone hybrid hill
in northern virtual extension so
dwelling
the application was called in by the
chief detective tourist council
um for a number of reasons and they
don't have the reasons
to call the application and that's why
it's considered by memphis today
here we have the location pad for the
application uh marked out in red
as you can see and it's in a residential
area
it has resident properties east and
south
with the highway to the west and further
residential properties
on the side of the highway there
again there's another aerial image the
application site outlined in red
just give
and the north there is an existing well
established
uh tree line and beyond that is a green
space
which is private next slide please
here we have highway access looking
north and
just to give a single track kind of
country lane and
and this is the start of the resident
properties and accessors
with the light adverse
residential light there
and here we have highway access looking
south and
again it widens over widens that out a
little bit um
here's looking at the application site
in kind of the context
and this is the front elevation with the
driveway
and access you can see there
it's like these and here's just closer
up
an image of the front elevation
churn but um single story bundle
next slide please after you speak up
this is looking from the front elevation
and towards the west
to give a bit of context when what is
west you can see the highway
to the bottom of the driveway there and
then your residential properties on the
inside
here's the rear elevation of the
property and stood along the back
boundary of the application site
i couldn't get it all in one shot so
it's been separate
i do
there apologize you can see the
neighboring properties can be terrace um
just behind
that just like that and then you've got
the boundary
to the left hand side
this is the south elevation and the
front elevation
of the left just to show the context
and between that and the navy boxes to
the south
you have a part of the application site
just down the side of the
south elevation then there's a small
park and
rear access to the kimberley terrace
properties and you can see kimberly
terrace rear elevations on the right
hand side there
again just another context image front
elevation of the property on the left
and the rear elevations of kimberly
terrace and just behind that
and you see the the boundary of the
terrace
properties and their immediate space and
the
uh kind of buildings just on the other
side of the hedge
there
just some views from those kimber
terrace um community areas
so this is looking back from uh number
two can be terrace and you can see
the application site uh the rooftop is
just like that
again this is from three kinder terrace
back from the private scene space
freedom is harris to the application
site
again just another post up from three
candy terrace
this is uh looking back from the fork
into terrace
the application site
again from five can do terrace
and this is from the residential on the
other side of the highway
and there was concerns from this
resident in terms of overlooking
uh from the balcony so this is looking
from their property looking back
into the application site you can see
just the other side of the hedge
and that tree on the right
here's the uh the existing site plan
and of the app of the first single story
bundle
here's the pose like that um
there's existing ground floor plan of
the assistant bungalow
and the proposed plans five bedrooms
and property again
existing elevations bundle
and the proposed elevations of property
material considerations in this case are
the principle of development
the impact on character appearance
renewable low carbon energy
impact on immunity access parking
highway safety
ecology and other matters
hopefully you will read my um committee
report
and separate sends out why i'm amending
this application for approval
if you have any other questions
thank you people
we have um four speakers down from this
one
one is a statement which will be read
out by the planning manager
the first speaker if you see mr andy
pine
exactly
he was to speak against it the next one
will be the statement then
[Music]
against the application
uh thank you chair can members hear me
okay
so i have a statement to be read out by
john harvest
i would like to register my strong
objection to this development on the
following grounds
the proposed height of the roof means
that redstone will be completely
overbearing for this location
and will have a negative impact on the
character of the area
on the updated plant there are still two
first floor windows on the rear of the
property
which will still open up my property and
allow people to look right into my
property
just westley anywhere and also
neighbouring properties on kimberley
terrace
this will mean my garden kitchen and two
of the bedrooms would be overlooked
the height of the boat will mean that
there will be a loss of light
levels in both my garden and the rear
rooms my property
kitchen and two bedrooms advice
if i could suggest a way forward could
be to keep the height of the roof as it
is
or even just raise it by maybe a
thousand millimeters
and have no additional windows or roof
windows on the rear of the property
and just convert the existing route by
doing a long conversion
and creating additional bedrooms where
the property is too small as it is
maybe on the front you just have some
belts windows or small doors and this
was acceptable to residents
who live towards the front of the bunker
in conclusion
by raising the roof level so much to
create the first floor
is going to make the property completely
overbearing the roof level
is a third higher than it is currently
it is out of heating and surrounding
area
it will cause loss of light levels and
will directly overlook the kitchen
two bedrooms and garden of wrestling
giving a total loss of privacy which is
completely unacceptable
thank you for reading this out of the
planning meeting meeting please keep me
updated
best wishes john harvest
thank you sean um
right so next speaker dandy pie
if you'd like to come to the front here
please because
we are having trouble in here if you'd
like to stand more or less like yellow
spotters
thank you for grabbing the problems
thank you you've got three minutes to
invest good morning my name is andy pi
i'm here today to represent the
kimberley terrace and hybrid hill
community
situated on the rural outskirts of
northern
the proposed scheme reflects
redevelopment of a single story
structure
to a two-story dwelling such a
redevelopment far exceeds any
description
of this being a mere extension in regard
to policy demo one
which relates to amenity considerations
when the development would not
significantly harm the amenities
of any neighboring occupiers or uses
there have been 18 objections from
neighboring occupiers
the clear reason for this is that the
impact of this proposal
will significantly harm the amenities of
neighboring occupiers
this proposal significantly reduces our
privacy and immunity space
due to the gargantuas ridge height
soffit level
and in the most severe cases in
pertinent elevational exposure
from two sides at a 45 degree angle
not just one elevation we will have to
live with this
for years to come this amenity space is
regularly used by neighboring families
and their children
to enjoy their outdoor garden space and
the sunlight
the sunlight calculated by the age which
provides information for when we are at
least
likely to be in our back gardens the
autumn solstice
this is a mistake the first floor
balcony which is proposed to be
15 and a half square meters is situated
on the front elevation
of the proposed building this will still
allow the occupiers to glare down
into the back gardens and conservatories
of families and retired residents of
highly heavy
in regard to dmo4 which relates to being
sympathetic to scale and density massing
and height ensure the amenities of
existing and future enabling rockets are
safe guarded the reason this bungalow
was first given planet commission
was because it fit within its
surroundings to allow a two-story
five-double bedroom structure
of this size would be distinctively out
of character
in terms of scale and height of the
contradictory
urban great local planet there has been
no consideration shown towards
harmonising the proposal to fit within
its natural surroundings
the hip roof falls way short of what we
consider to be a meaningful change
the community has suggested on more than
one occasion that the equilibrium to
this situation
would be to increase the existing roof
pitch and convert the loft space
like so many other property owners have
done in the area
but this has been ignored twice i would
like to leave you with one final thought
is it considered acceptable to demise
the amenities
of 16 families and their children for
the benefit of one
who do not currently reside at the
property
thank you for listening to our community
thank you and
[Music]
our next speaker is in support is the
applicant
john samwell if you'd like to address
the community thank you from there
and you've got three minutes to address
that okay
thanks uh my name is john sandler i'm
the applicant in this case
i live in biddy foot in a four bedroom
home and they have five children
i have worked in biddy foot for over 26
years for the last eight years working
from home
we purchased this property with a view
to build a five-bedroom home
to accommodate our family and working
conditions the existing building
sits on a 32 meter length by 20 meter
wide plot and this proposed building
will be 50 meters length
by 12.2 meters wide therefore i don't
consider that this proposal was too
large for the flop
and already has ample parking houses to
the front and rear are over 30 meters
away
kimberly terraces to the south sitting
at roughly 30 degree angle
and his closest is 22 meters away and
furthest is 40 meters away
moving on to objections most stem from
kimberley terrace where
only 4 out of the 12 proposed uh
properties
number two to five look directly onto
the proposed southern elevation
which has no second story windows from
the rear of the terrace
the random material planning points
raised to a loss of light overbearing
and
overlooking or loss of privacy since
2005 two-story buildings have been
granted either end of kimberley terrace
two more to the front all at higher
elevations than my proposal
significantly 77 kimberly park has a
gable end
directly opposite number one kimberley
terrace with no hip
end and at a higher elevation with only
16 meters separation
but not considered overbearing kimberly
terrace enjoys
gardens of over 16 metres in length with
fences and out buildings
that screen my property loss of privacy
from the balcony
uh was addressed by addition of a
privacy screen
when considering overbearing and light
only ground floor living spaces are
normally considered
not second story windows or end of
gardens as we've seen in some of the
objections
as overbearing is subjective the most
common methodology used
is separation distance and the 45 degree
test
on separation a wall has no a wall with
no second story window it's permittable
at a minimum of 12 to 15 meters where i
have 22
using the 45 degree test uh from any
surrounding buildings there is no issues
raised
finally on light the rear of kimberly
terrace is northeast facing with the sun
rising behind
the terrace and setting towards harlem
point so at no point in my property
overshadowed
the approach of adding a second story
has been actively encouraged by the
government with the august 2020 changes
to permissible development rights
throughout the planning process we've
worked closely with the planning
department to ensure
our plans meet planning regulations and
dress neighbors concerns where possible
during this process we have changed our
scheme four times for uh following
requests from planning department
these were lowering the overall height
adding a end adding a privacy screen
and finally recently agreed to
preservation on apple tree
i am pleased to see the committee report
is supportive of the scheme
and is recommended approval i hope you
therefore approve this application
thank you thank you
and our final final speaker is
councillor
haynes who's the board member for apple
i'll press on um i'm very concerned
about this application which if approved
will blight the lives of residents
kimberly teresa lived very native
application site
contrary to the applicant's assertions
and the planning officer's statement in
the committee report
it should be apparent that the proposal
to increase the height significantly in
the present building
will drastically block light and cast a
shadow over these people's gardens and
houses
and particularly severely over seven of
the dwellings directly behind the
proposed building
this will significantly reduce the
amount of sunshine in their backyards
which they are present in joy during the
spring and summer months
and will make their houses darker during
the winter
these people have worked hard and
invested a lot of money
to making their homes attractive places
to live
but they have now faced a future with
despair
furthermore from what i've been told
they simply cannot understand why the
applicant has failed to talk
proposal through with them but he's
going ahead with a development which
will have such an adverse effect on
their lives
on this matter i refer you to para128 of
the mdpf requiring an applicant to work
closely at an early stage with a
community
in formulating development proposals and
local plan policy sto4 para 329
which states there should be early and
meaningful engagement with the local
community from pre-application
discussions
it should be clear to anyone that the
building will severely impact the
immediateness of the neighboring
residents
local planned policy dm01 clearly states
that development will not be supported
if it's significantly harms
in the communities of neighbouring
occupiers
and paragraph 12.3 a specifically
cites the loss of daylight through
overshadowing
furthermore policy dmo1 refers to the
adverse effects of noise and vibration
neighbours and i hope that from your
virtual side visit
you have seen how close the development
site is to the back gardens of kimberly
terrace
and that you can therefore imagine the
hell residents will go through
suffering noise vibration and dust from
the construction
process and then being plunged into
overshadowing once the building is
completed
i refer also to policy dno2c
concerning a development not being
supported if there is likely to be an
unacceptable levels of noise and
vibration
in the construction period residents
will also have to experience being
overlooked in their gardens and houses
from the large windows and balconies
proposed in the new
new dwelling despite the use of the paid
glass
[ __ ] residents opposite in new lilly
close
and behind the proposed building of the
bungalow called westley
where there will be direct views into
bedrooms from the balcony
residents and guests of the new dwelling
will have views over the gardens of
kimberley terrace when leaning over the
south west elevation banistery
and there will be views into some of the
terrace gardens from first floor windows
in the northeast elevation
the overlooking will be compounded by
noise from users of the proposed balcony
on the southeast side
and the adjoining dining room and
bedroom when the doors are open
amazingly the environment protection
officer in these comments on the
application
acknowledges the close proximity of the
proposed dwelling to kimberley terrace
has been detrimental to labour's
immunity but it doesn't consider this as
a reason for refusal of the application
instead he recommends what he terms a
restriction or construction hours to
seven in the morning to seven at night
and saturday mornings my comment is that
if this is considered a restriction then
what is not a restriction
starting at five in the morning and
ending at nine at night that
please note too that the proposal is to
extend the existing bundle of form a
five-bedroom property
and i ask you to think about this
proposal very carefully
and then please consider how one can
possibly classify the process as an
extension when the height of the
bangalore
the bungalow will be increased by so
much
whether existing walls of the bungalow
support such a large so-called extension
surely the walls will have to be
strengthened to support the extra height
and surely this will involve
would involve demolition of the bank
alone so i suggest the planning
application
is inaccurate in stating that the
proposal is for an extension
rather than the construction of a
totally new building
as to the proposal the property should
have the bedrooms
have five bedrooms please consider the
implications of this
if the property is to accommodate five
or more people living there or visiting
then imagine what it'd be like for the
neighbors from that number of people
sitting on the balcony or in the garden
only a few meters away from timberlake
ferris gardens and if the property is
used for holiday purposes
please imagine the implications of
different people staying at the property
every week or other week causing even
more disturbance
consider too the proposed parking
provision is there really enough room
for five cars of water property without
some spilling into the narrow lane to
park
i refer to the requirements of lp policy
dm06 on this point
and i despair the case officer's view
that there is a reasonable
reasonable amount of on-street parking
and his view that traffic
slows down outside the site because
because it's approaching a built-up
area from your site visit you will see
that the lane is narrow
there is limited visibility in both
directions and there is a junction
opposite the site at living close
i put it to you that the pro-closed
house is totally inappropriate for the
site
and as such it flies flaunts design
policy dno4 and local plan
which states in clause a that the
development should be appropriate
and sympathetic in scale density massing
height layout
appearance fenestration materials and
relationships buildings and landscape
features
in the local neighbourhood furthermore
cause these stakes and development
should reinforce the key characteristics
and special qualities of the area in
which
the development is proposed i also refer
to para130 and 132 of the
nppf regarding good design and effect on
character and area
and suggest to you the contrary to the
case officers view
the key characteristic characteristic of
the neighbouring properties
is victorian terrorist housing at
kimberly terrace
and modern terrorist houses at kimberley
park
and not detached five bedroom properties
such as the one we proposed
i further submit because of the
innovation of the site
above the level of highbury hill the
proposed building that will have even
more of an adverse impact on
neighbouring buildings
given these factors i'm puzzled and i'm
sure the residents of kimberley terrace
are too
but the case officer is satisfied that
the tests on the policy dm
25 have been met with this application
it is glaringly obvious to me the
contrary to his recommendation
and to uh to refer that contrary to his
recommendation
recommendation regarding the three tests
the proposed wedding will have a
significant
adverse effect on the surrounding
properties
parking revision is that in that of
course most importantly
there will be a significantly adverse
impact on the immunity of occupants of
neighboring properties
and i quote that line from the policy
in conclusion councillors i fervently
hope they agree with me that the
proposed development is totally wrong
for the site
and that if approved it will allow one
person to like the lives of the small
community
of around 16 families which has been
established at kindly
these appreciate the residents are not
opposed to the african changing
bangalore to increase the number of
bedrooms but what they propose
is that the applicant applies for dormer
room extension and not
totally unreasonable solutions look
forward the press
bungalow is relatively unobtrusive and
with normal windows at the front will
remain so
and the residents will be happy with
this please refuse the applicational
grounds of severe effect on neighbours
immunity
failure to consult neighbors at
pre-application stage
[Music]
unacceptable
you